hello everyone
welcome back to big mood what do we have
here welcome
welcome welcome hi it's gina hi it's
jess hi it's nikki
hi it's time
[Applause]
well today we have um some pretty fun
things you guys are really going to get
to know us very very well because
what we did you think you know us you
don't know [ __ ]
you don't know [ __ ] you're about to
really get to know us and so
what we did is we took a whole bunch of
quizzes that i gave to the girls
and what we're gonna do is go over these
quizzes yeah and then we have we'll have
all the quizzes that we took
linked uh so you can take them too you
take them too
send them to your friend find out about
yourself send them to your boyfriend it
is really enlightening to know
like what why you do the things you do i
mean and these quizzes are not like
super [ __ ] like professional or
anything so they're kind of like a fun
thing but i think
they do offer some insight so like
they're not like they're
saying all encompassing that i am not
ned stark
wait wait just just to really draw in
the audience there's some
there's a crazy sexual oh do we want to
just listen to what they are really yeah
okay so i'll list them so we have a sex
personality test we have a bdsm
we have a what's your turn on trigger
a kinsey scale test which is where which
is where you're gonna see
where exactly how fluid you are sexually
right sexually fluid
gina are you okay gina stop playing with
that yeah so you know sexuality is a
spectrum you want to see where exactly
you are on that spectrum yes next one is
an attachment style
quiz and then we have another one that's
an attachment style quiz but they give
us
slightly different insight so we're
going to go through
both of them this dick and then
trying to get them in yeah weirder
vaginas boobies
yeah and then there's an ideal
relationship structure
quiz which is where you like what kind
of commitment
you like like what you know are you and
you like open relationships are you
fully monogamous
right all of that um also we're doing
the classic love language test because
they say over time your love language
changes so we're gonna find out if any
of
our love languages have changed and then
the final one that we have here is
an apology language so just like a love
language how
you receive love and how you give love
is a particular way you also
end up having an apology language that
resonates with you the best so when
someone has wronged you
you would like for them to apologize in
this particular way yeah and i didn't
even realize
how strong i felt about that because as
we were taking the quiz i was reading
some of the
answer choices and i was like oh that
with [ __ ] business
you try to apologize that way i'm more i
was already triggered
and i was reading those scenarios like i
didn't i couldn't stop crying
so these quizzes are great oh no that
was well i cry when i'm frustrated oh
yeah it wasn't because i was weak
and sobbing at it because i was so
[ __ ] mad totally justified
thank you yeah so that's a long list of
quizzes and they were they were actually
really fun to take so
we suggest you guys take them exactly
check them out and then shout outs to
shan budrum our homegirl shan what's up
because a lot of these quizzes we
actually
i actually got him from her site her
website where she's
talking about her book called game of
desire and i just finished reading that
book isn't it a good book really good
it's a really good book shout out shan i
love you
so all right let's go through our first
test here okay
everyone bust out your phones your
results all right so the first one is
a sex personality test and this how does
this get scored
so this is out of a hundred you're gonna
get a number out of a hundred
and this is like your spiciness rating
i'm offended
so it's gonna call me bland
[Laughter]
but yeah so then um i guess i'll go
first okay and then we'll go around
so mine i got a 43 out of a hundred
spicy it's almost halfway yeah so my
result says
your results indicate that you are
comfortable experimenting sexually but
haven't explored a wide variety of
options from a great palette or from the
great palette of sex
you do have a creative nature which
keeps your sexual liaisons
satisfactorily spicy but you aren't
the most adventurous love bug on the
planet you seem to have discovered what
pleases you and plan to stick with it
as long as you are sexually fulfilled
keep it up i got the exact
same description but i'm at a 58. oh
yeah this
wait so i didn't know that we were
supposed to write down the whole entire
thing so you just wrote down the number
i just wrote on the number sorry
so i gotta find the results i was very
explicit with my directions when i gave
you these quizzes
gina you're like a c student yeah very
clear right now
she's getting very clear she is very
gracious i know she's getting
she's generous i don't want to say these
get degrees
they do hold on she's not wrong so do
these yeah
gina what's your number at least 70. oh
my gosh
experimental fairly comfortable so it
says it pretty much says that you're
fairly comfortable with your sexuality
and the things like everything that you
want to do
the only things that i was very very
much against was um
swinging or anything was sharing my mans
or sharing myself i don't like that
yeah i was against that and i i don't
like anything that leaves marks
or anything like bruises or i love
marks or anything like that me too i
actually was like no
no really i like it to like just shock
me a little bit but
not for it to be actually painful or
like actually like
hard enough to yeah because there was a
range so when we were taking these
quizzes it was like
like dis like absolutely disagree
somewhat disagree
neutral somewhat agree absolutely agree
and so for the bruises thing i was just
like somewhat disagree
mm-hmm just like you know yeah something
like that gave me this perfect
situation where i would like that yeah
what about you jess
yeah i mean i'm in the middle too um and
i
i found this i mean this quiz is funny
honestly it's just someone's opinion
right like whoever wrote it it's just
their opinion so they're saying it was
on psychology today.com
yeah but i mean it's just psychology
it's just someone's opinion still right
because
but then i thought it was kind of funny
because they're like your sexual
liaisons are
satisfactorily spicy so they're just
like
you're so spicy yeah i was like
excuse me you've never had sex with me
yeah you don't know how [ __ ] spicy i
can be in bed like
a meeting yeah i'm just like like why
does it have to be um cheating
or painful for it to be enjoyable i'm
just like i don't
i i felt a little bit offended by the
quiz itself because i was like
why do i have to be willing to like let
my man sleep with another [ __ ] or have
him
hit me upside the head with the
telephone pole in order to beat you
don't judge
in order to be good in bed like stop
sign [ __ ]
well i wouldn't say to be good in bed is
to see how adventurous and open you are
to
sexual experience they're calling it
spicy as if like if you're not spicy
then you're bland and you're boring and
i just you are
taking it that way they're like oh if
you were spicy before i was [ __ ]
it's just like flour think of something
spicy i can't handle spice because i'm
like why do i want to be in pain while
i'm eating food like
i would just give me a medium enough for
me to be like you're amazing
enough for the flavor and look at your
husband he enjoys that torture
yeah everyone's different exactly he
likes the spicy
so it's just a crazy scale it's not
necessarily like your sex is
like if your sex personality quiz came
out to be at 24. i want to see jess get
defensive over more sex
oh yeah i'm defensive go [ __ ] them right
now and show them
show them yourself when you know you're
good at something and someone tells you
you're not you know how [ __ ]
pissed you get come on i feel you girl
you're a daddy girl you suck that dick
with 70 spicy
you talk up a good spice oh i'll walk
the walk do you want to come over later
yeah
[Laughter]
now you're agreeing with them
that's amazing you pass on the crazy
scale though
[ __ ] you do this for mine was just like
yeah i'm down for anything just don't
sleep with other people you know don't
murder me or sleep with other people
exactly and we're good yeah that's cool
yeah
so if you guys are curious to see what's
inside that quiz go ahead yeah like
like if you take the quiz yourself
you'll you'll see where you write on it
and then you could kind of see how we
yeah like reaction stuff just sounded
like a lot of work
i'm not here to do a lot of work i'll
suck your dick but like
that yeah i don't know i don't want to
work yeah mm-hmm all right let's move on
to the bdsm
test so i'll admit i i took this test
before i didn't even need to take it
i know exactly do you still have your
results though uh yeah i have i know
what my results are and i know how to
describe it you memorize
you all of these are these numbers
gina she didn't take it she said she's
just like i'll do all of them oh no i c
minus just before i just know my top
three because those are for the ones
that mattered to me i didn't know that
okay yeah yeah you don't have time to
retake it right now well
we have we have all the explanations
anyway so if you know what yours is like
my top three is i'm submissive um yeah
i'm a brat
and i am pray do you remember your
percentage those are in my top five one
two three four five six
i don't but i just know that those are
my top top three yeah so i'm very
submissive in bed i am ready like i
want to do what you tell me to do but i
don't want to give it to you that easily
yes and then i'm also praying i like
being hunted i like when my man is
the uh the primal he hunts after he
hunts me he like bites me
like like i scratch and yeah interesting
tiff what are you so you'll have a full
set yeah i have the full set here so
um so if when you're taking this quiz
it's like
okay well i'm very freaking vanilla okay
yeah no actually my results came out 98
brat wow that's your top one
wow do you want to do you have the
description for it because i do oh yeah
go for it so uh
brad is it says brats are in essence
naughty submissives they find
disobedience a form of playfulness
rather than letting their dominant
down yeah so uh yeah so they think the
disobedience is playful rather than
upsetting the partner yeah okay so and
require a compatible dominant who will
not only teach them a lesson but will
also accept that any number of lessons
might still not necessarily change this
behavior
rats typically pair up with brat tamers
well obviously but anyway so that's your
top one
yeah apparently so 98 brat uh second one
is 64 percent
rope bunny oh i got that one too what's
wrong with that getting tied up
really yeah how did i not know this
yeah we never have like literature marks
i'm expecting if you're into role play
that someday you're gonna show up with
bruises around your wrist never
tried to escape from a trunk flyer
jesus christ damn
have you ever put the rope between your
leg ropes and try to start a fire and
get yourself out
now
you get it jess you're spicy
it's the one white girl it's like we do
use spices when we cook okay
all right lemon butter
hey i'm offended all right what else are
you two um
uh the third one is fifty nine percent
switch
yeah um i don't have the ones for switch
but i think that's kind of obvious like
yeah you go back and forth from being
dominant or submissive yeah like i don't
necessarily have to be
one the whole time or like i i i find
pleasure
being dominant sometimes you like the
variance of
different levels of play yeah but you
know what though it's more like
like if i feel like i need to be
dominant then i'm like okay then i guess
i'll be dominant this round because it's
necessary but i don't know if i would
actually like crave it like i want to be
dominant
that's that's not really but it rated so
high on your list that's strange yeah
yeah maybe because i was
just the way you answered it yeah it was
probably the way i answered it all right
nikki what were your
results all right so i'm 92 submissive
let's go yeah
85 rope bunny oh you know what's weird
though
i know that's it's weird because i've
only done that one time
like and i can't remember a lot of
questions like that on the thing
i think i just answered a lot of like i
like to be restrained like a lot of
times steve will like hold oh so it may
not be the ropes but you like yeah
the restraint and like not being able to
move different forms of restraint
exactly and then i got 85 percent
degrade
degrading degradation you like to be
like grated
yes oh you slept like when he treats me
like nothing i love it yeah i do
me too i also got brat brat and
degrading are tied actually
[Music]
interesting so we're just gonna slide
right on over to me yeah
slide it in all right well i got 87
vanilla
that's what i thought i was bitching
about not being spicy
you're not you're not holding down for
the hoits jess
oh my god vanilla people enjoy regular
standard sex and relationship models
nothing wrong with that as long as
you're having fun vanilla's peripherals
she's like a french vanilla okay like
she's got a little black dots in there
like yeah it's not just a regular
vanilla
there's nothing wrong with vanilla sucks
man whatever works for me it works for
you dude
she's spicy yeah i don't know i okay
well anyway i'll
and then i agree i got yeah i got 81
submissive
okay and then i got voyeur oh okay
then i got brat masochist and pray
so um i guess i'll explain the ones that
we haven't really covered
i mean obviously a voyeur if you know
what that is they enjoy watching
nakedness or sexual activity of other
people what was your perspective
48 do anyone else get age player
okay oh mine was zero
i did get daddy slash mommy and that was
42
i don't like daddy's stuff ew not mommy
no
turn me on you know why i think it's
because i answered certain questions
with like oh like i tend to be nurturing
in my relationship
but i thought i forgot that i was taking
a sexy related
quiz no thanks um and then it said
masochist
which is 34 percent enjoy receiving pain
from their partner certain types usually
in a sexual context is
independent of pain tolerance it's
purely about the ability to enjoy or
get aroused by certain levels of pain
masochists typically pair up with sadist
so 34 so i've had a little bit of
experimentation with that like i dated
this french guy last year and he would
like slap the [ __ ] out of my butt and
like choke me a little bit and i thought
that was fun
with the baguette sorry not with the
baguette no
but it wasn't like uh what i imagine a
lot of media like
i don't want a lot of bdsm but like that
was kind of enjoyable
but some when it i don't know sometimes
it gets to be too much
but i don't know i just feel like a lot
of times people use abuse and sex
because they were abused so yeah
sometimes it gets a little over
glorified as like oh you're the fun one
because
i just feel like sometimes we make it
like oh everyone has to punch each other
in order to be good at sex and i don't
want it
other girls to feel like if you're not
getting punched in the face that you're
not
good at sex and you're not fun oh yeah
you know what i don't know like
there's a there's a porn right it needs
to be something you're comfortable with
right
like it's just some people like a little
bit more than other people
yeah but question why like if you're
gonna if you're gonna engage in
activities that are physically abusive
like get
like question like why do i like this or
like do i really like this or is it
being
put on me and then you and then you
you'll know like
whether it's but i just don't like the
whole idea of like
vanilla is bad no like so if you
if you're not punching me in the face
and i'm bad at bed i'm like
i don't like that idea subjective not
submissive subjection
for you it's just about how well you're
connecting with
the other person and like creating an
environment and like an experience
that's something you're going to
remember and it's going to be
it's going to be special part of your
day not like oh we have to beat each
other up and tie each other up otherwise
it's
worthless yeah well this is a bdsm quiz
so i think right
so like if i answered no to
do i want to be walked around town on a
leash i answered no then it's like wow
you're a vanilla and it's like
okay you got your kink that was yeah so
i would say bdsm for me
put me at a zero yeah just put me out of
zero because i mean
i'm okay with a little slap like the guy
that i dated you know like he'll
slap my butt and had little finger marks
i had little like red marks for like 48
hours or a little bruise and i was like
oh that's cute like that was sexy but
like
when it comes to majority of it it's a
no for me mm-hmm
it's like getting a little temporary
tattoo sex
uh before we get to that um type of
business
there's usually some undressing that
needs to be done yeah
what might they undress oh well you know
they might take off your third
love bra which is the perfect fit bra
and
my personal favorite and i wear this bra
every day because i have many many
different third love bras
her man takes off her bra and he's like
wow this just fits you perfectly wow
yeah
that's great the cup size is perfect
your half cup size is perfect
do they tie each other up with straps on
the rope you know
oh yeah i don't know i'm trying to make
that work it works i got a third left
bra
yeah this one's super cute i love how it
just hugs my breast this is
and yeah it just it's a really good fit
and also
you know how you know when you wear your
bra and it's a bad fit
and it actually digs into your shoulders
and it digs into your sides and creates
that like back fat area that's just so
uncomfortable or your
your boob is spilling out or your cups
are too big and your boobs are drowning
inside
i've had all these problems but not with
third love because
first you take a you take the fitting
room quiz
which is a new and improved version of
the fit finder quiz
and it focuses on size breast shape
current fit issues and your personal
style to deliver bras and underwear that
are perfect for you
fit stylists are available for
one-on-one chats to answer
any questions if you have any and they
have the perfect fit
promise if you don't love it every
single customer has 60 days to return
and returns and exchanges are free and
super super easy
so break up with your bad bra and fall
in love with better bras and underwear
from classic lace that actually feels
soft to their number one rated 24 7
classic
t-shirt bra check out all the exclusive
styles at thirdlove.com
third love knows your one true fit is
out there so right now they are offering
our listeners
twenty percent off your first order go
to third love
dot com slash big mood now and find your
perfect fitting bra
and get twenty percent off your first
purchase that's thirdlove.com
big mood for 20 off today
speaking of underwear you want to make
sure you never have skid marks on them
oh my god
yes you can definitely prevent that with
hello tishi bidet
hooray because hello tissue will keep
your butt so clean you'll never leave a
skidmark squeaky
squeaky clean you've been pooping the
wrong way your whole life and you have
no idea do you
the brand new hello tissue 3.0 modern
bidet attachment is here and it's
stylish eco-friendly easy to install and
affordable
it attaches to your existing toilet
requires no electricity or additional
plumbing
and cuts toilet paper use by eighty
percent because all you gotta do is take
a little square and dab it dry
so the hello tissue bidet pays for
itself in a few months
plus every hello tissue bidet attachment
comes with a 60-day
risk-free guarantee and a 12-month
warranty
our listeners can go to hellotissue.com
big mood for 10
off plus free shipping get 10 off plus
free shipping and get your butt clean
at hellotishie.combigmood again that's
healthtushy.com
big mood all right guys let's move on to
the next quiz
it is what is your turn on trigger and
i personally got desire oh same
it says skip the filters you need to be
told directly that you're desired it is
important that your partner
says what they're thinking before after
and during sex especially
if what they're thinking is damn you're
sexy in short
dirty talk is your [ __ ] yeah it's good
to know these things because
like a lot of times i think if you get
with a new person
and they know like this worked with
their ex and they keep trying to turn
you on that way
but that's not what turns you on you
have it's good to know your own turn on
trigger so you can communicate that
to them yeah or if you don't necessarily
like
super romantic things but they're like
oh you know i
worked with the last girl if i had a
bunch of flowers all throughout the
living room but if i come home and i
just start sneezing because i'm allergic
to plants
that's not going to work for me and it
sneezes it tightens up your yeah yeah
so it might work that could be fun yeah
my allergies
could that would
if you sneeze it's like little kegels if
you're sneezing a lot during sex it
could add something i'm spicy
imagine if you're singing
during sex he's on top he's got a
[ __ ] pepper grub
sneezing just tell me when to stop you
know when you sneeze that [ __ ]
[ __ ] creates a yeah hey just try it
try it yeah i'm the same with you i like
um
to be praised as like a brat submissive
i like to be praised you know so i like
hearing things
during sex i like when you tell me that
i'm hot tell me i'm doing good and stuff
like that i
see i like that in bed but that doesn't
turn me on like if i'm coming home from
work like because i think one of the
prompts is like
if you're coming home from work like
what's going to get you in the mood the
fastest
no not that because i'm usually like so
like tired and like exhausted from the
day like i need
like i need like i want to hear your
[ __ ] okay like
don't tell me i'm pretty i know you're
lying
through it mine is mental which i kind
of knew already i've talked about this
before but um yeah if you're not
connected mentally first physical
is hardly an option you are a
sapiosexual that's the term that i
learned
like i no one's attractive to me until
they have a
good conversation or make me laugh you
see that yeah so someone who's turned on
by intelligence and this feeling
at one with someone um through
conversation is a massive part of your
sexual
arousal cycle your partners must
understand that an intellectually
stimulating conversation
is often a pre prerequisite to
stimulating you anywhere else
a person's values and morals may also
play a huge role for determining sexual
compatibility for you
if they have a very different belief
system you can sense you'll want
very different things out of a sexual
experience
yeah pretty much pretty much a lot of
people are like that
yeah in fact like the first time stephen
i had sex um
it was like after sharing our favorite
snl sketches
and like we just kept going back and
forth making each other laugh and i knew
we had the same exact sense of humor
yeah and it turned me on so much that we
just had to like just
being nice i love that how about you
jess
mine was environmental and i that wasn't
immediately obvious to me but like the
more i thought about it i was like yeah
that's kind of true
so this one says do that yeah i totally
see that like freaking out about the
i know i wasn't really aware necessarily
that was a sexual thing for me as well
it says you're sensitive about your
setting and your sensory experiences
some people think that candles
cleanliness and intentional
settings are for special occasions but
for you it's the status quo
you need the vibe to be set before you
set it off in the bedroom it may be
impossible for you to think dirty
thoughts if you can see dirty clothes
in your peripheral vision you may also
be into sacred cleansing crystals no
[ __ ] you're wrong
your partners have to make an effort to
set the mood in the space that they want
you in
or they need to give you time to to do
that yourself to set up the space before
the fun can come in so
i guess it's um i'm like one of those
ocd people so like i don't want to be
[ __ ] in the middle of a trailer park
trash
dump oh that's how steve is too i'm like
put me in the bathroom and rest a
really bad sports bar well i've done
that
so i guess there's a line
i don't know i mean that for me i guess
that crosses into oh we're doing
something
spontaneous naughty out in public but
then like if it's normal sex it's like
ew like the sheets are [ __ ] your bed
smells like that's true
i'm not having sex in this bed it's
disgusting you know like i don't know
i guess that's that's very true yeah
yeah we're all about different
oh environmental was my second
yeah yeah oh interesting like i feel
like i you know the ones that were
environment were the second highest yeah
we like to be
wanted yeah but you know what i didn't
know that about myself
because when i was taking the this this
quiz was really difficult for me because
i'm like
i don't know then i tried like imagining
myself i'm like okay would this really
get me turned on
i'm like okay fine let's go with that
one but it wasn't
easy for me to like go through this quiz
and be like oh for sure this one or for
sure that one
yeah some of them are a little difficult
for me too right
to choose because i'm like yeah all i
mean all of these are the bare minimum
like for you know like tell me i'm
wanted your bed sheets need to be
yeah and we need to be that way mentally
connected yeah
yeah that's it you need to be all of
them yeah all right next one
is the kinsey scale quiz oh my god y'all
are gonna laugh unless y'all got the
same ones i probably got the same ones
probably got the same one well let's
find out do you want to go first gina
sure strictly
the description is funny gina read the
description oh you don't have the
tiff do you have the description i don't
have that oh my god okay you're
straighter than a ruler wearing
oh go ahead jess oh yes you're
straighter than a ruler wearing black
socks with sandals what does that mean
is that just nerdy ruler you're
straighter than a ruler wearing black
socks with sandals it says every sexual
thought you've ever had has been for a
member of the other sex and that'll
probably never change
your sexuality is about as fluid as the
polar ice caps
why are they insulting us global warming
is melting the ice caps a little so i
think i'm actually a bit stronger than
those ice caps
interesting i feel ashamed for being
straight no i'm just kidding oh
great shame i love you i love women i
think they're so beautiful but no part
of me wants to have sex with them
they're saying anything sexual or put
anything in them
yeah we have no gay representation here
when you look at a beautiful woman
you're like oh my god that girl's really
hot or that girl's really pretty yeah
don't even want to make out with her
don't touch it nope nope yeah that's
very normal
well i got mostly headers oh wow
i kind of knew that already though yeah
i mean the porn i watch
i guess i do have a fantasy which is
getting serviced by a woman i don't want
to service her
but anyway i got uh you're mostly
straight
but you're open to new ideas and
experiences maybe you've had a passing
thought or fantasy and maybe you've
actually thought about pursuing those
impulses
your sexuality is defined a little more
fluid than most
so out of the three of us
who would you want to service yeah no
that's gross
sisters that's creepy i know you guys
want a hand
it's like asking which one of your
brothers do you want to [ __ ] yeah yeah
that's true
you know how um straight i am but
remember when i told you guys go
straight are you
okay but you guys remember when um i
texted y'all and i was like oh there's
this girl that like i've literally
never thought i'd be attracted to yeah i
was like
for some reason kind of attracted to her
you were you're attracted to her energy
right her energy
yeah it wasn't even really that sexual
but i'm like talking i guess
it's not you nikki
but yeah so like she's in denial yeah i
don't know that was weird but
yeah i still don't think that i'm
interested at all and ever pursue and
i don't know oh i did one time have a
dream that elizabeth hurley picked me
out of
everybody else and yeah it was back in
the day and
yeah very dated and
um yeah for some reason the fact that
she picked me
even though i did it wasn't didn't want
to have sex with her like i just like
did because she picked me and like i
felt special
i had a lesbian dream once but then i
woke up and i was like like in the dream
it was really hot you know whatever cool
but then when i woke up i was like
yeah you know yeah um yeah
i relate okay next one attachment style
oh what the [ __ ]
actually wrote the whole thing down this
time oh nice you didn't
do it was poppy paste chinese a tiny one
she typed it
oh no i caught me paste okay no but
she's saying she wrote it down so like i
picture her they're like
subscribing
okay so this one this this first quiz is
from
gameofdesirethegameofdesire.com and then
it's
showing you like game of thrones
characters but it has nothing to do with
game of thrones it's more
talking about your attachment style and
so for me personally
i got secure it says [ __ ] what
aren't we lucky yeah i know
all of us and none of us should have
that answer
really i feel like you're close like
this one but
steve was like i'm gonna go out with the
boys this weekend and um
that doesn't qualify for like um or
sometimes he
he's talked to all of you like on the
phone individually like for a long time
about issues and i feel like if we
weren't secure and he was just talking
to another girl
for that long like well it's not really
about you being jealous of steve i know
yeah so
they actually explained it in the in the
paragraph here so it says this is the
ideal way to attach
to others and it's this is not just in
romantic relationships it's like in
friendships too
like it's just an attachment style to
your family your friends all that
okay it says and the good news is
roughly half of the population is
securely attached
people with secure attachment freely
display interest and affection towards
others but are also comfortable being
alone
they make boundaries and they stick to
them they aren't possessive nor
are they passive or dismissive they
they're capable of accepting rejection
and have little trouble
trusting people see these are [ __ ]
because i didn't score that but
when you saying that i'm like i'm
comfortable being alone i'm okay with
rejection because i know it's not really
about me it's just about
the connections not making their being
there or whatever so
i don't know like yeah that's why like
when
the quiz like it'll prompt you like
certain scenarios
and you just kind of like place yourself
in that situation it's like how would
you respond in those situations
so what did you guys get i got uh
anxious preoccupied which totally makes
sense it says 20 of the population are
said to be anxious preoccupied meaning
people who are often nervous and
stressed about their relationship
they crave intimacy but they lack
confidence that anyone will truly love
them
they worry a lot that someone will lose
interest in them and choose someone else
they have a hard time trusting people
but also have an even harder time
letting go
i think that's pretty accurate because
i'm very like
kind of like doomsday
kind of yeah like why is this happening
you know what i'm out i'm out
like i don't want to think yeah it was
the beginning of a relationship for me
i don't think i would have scored secure
because there's different ways
i think too that you can go through i
don't think it's such a static thing
well but when you go through the
scenarios that they listed like
the other ones didn't apply at all
because it like the
when i picture steve doing those things
i'm like
yeah i have no pro there's no problem
like zero problem there's no like
oh i'm not gonna talk to him for a day
or like i need to my own time or
whatever
it's just like yeah there's i don't see
a problem yeah so
mine especially for me mine is like in
the beginning of the relationship
yeah the beginning for me is like the
wild west yes shit's crazy
like where are we what are you doing
like are you talking to someone else who
the [ __ ] and then
once it's like settled in we're
committed once it's once it's secure
then i'm like all right we're
we're cool you know um but for the most
part i am like the anxious type like
i've how many times have i
you know talked to you guys like why the
[ __ ] am i not getting a text back well
yeah and then what i would do is uh well
this is what i used to do but i'll be
like all right i'm out
like i don't want to deal with you i'm
going to leave first so that you can't
hurt me
yeah it's very like it's an anxious
thing for me i'm 100
that in a beginning of a relationship
yeah that's why this quiz i feel like
could be a little misleading because
it's like i don't think you're
like one thing all the time yeah well if
it's about your
current relationship which is like my
partner xyz that's what this that's how
the prompts
if you don't have one then you're just
thinking of like if you just maybe like
because i'm single right like i'm not in
a relationship so i'm having to do these
relationship things where i'm thinking
like well if i guess i met someone new
and he did that so then in my head i'm
like
yeah probably thinking through that
beginning stages type of
what did you end up feeling well so i
got fearful avoidant
this is a combination of dismissive
avoidant and anxious preoccupied
these are the people that push others
away not because they want space but
they fear once you get too close
you will want space from them what does
that mean
oh you would want you would get bored of
them oh okay you are torn between
fearing and craving a level of
commitment
they don't think anyone can provide
they are torn between fearing and
craving love yeah i don't know
so i don't know what character in the
show did it say
oh we didn't even know i didn't say that
um
no one else is saying here catlin stark
oh my god
then okay so this is what can you
explain to them what we're talking about
game of thrones yeah right because this
quiz is
it's really where it's one of those
weird quizzes that tells you your game
of thrones character attachment style
like it tells you
your attachment style and then which
game of thrones character is mostly like
that
yeah yeah which was weird because i
pretty much skipped over that part
like missandei had a secure relationship
style isn't she the redhead
no she's the the the uh the girl that
falls in love with the slave um
grey worm yeah warrior she was the
right-hand woman
yeah danny oh i forgot about her
mine is i got jamie lannister and
daenerys oh she was really pretty
yeah okay yeah yeah yeah i got [ __ ]
tyrion lannister cersei lannister
wait she was a sir yeah yeah remember
she was a knight but was she
considered a woman you know yeah she's
okay they call it women sir yeah or i
guess right because
she ignited unofficially i totally
missed that
um i just thought it was brand of tarth
but anyway start peter baelish
littlefinger the little finger strange
bro
[Laughter]
you're in different stages right like
yeah i agree too
because definitely you might feel
differently in the beginning
i mean for sure you feel differently in
the beginning of a relationship versus
like 10 years later
but i i don't know it's interesting to
me because i took this
exact same quiz when case
like when my marriage was at a really
low point
and i still got secure so i don't maybe
you deal with the issues securely i
don't know
attachment style wise i don't know very
interesting
yeah i just know like i never worry
about my relationship ever
like must be nice i mean but it took a
while
you know but i mean i guess in the
beginning i didn't worry either with him
in particular but every other
relationship in the beginning was just
really just filled with anxiety you know
it's interesting i have had moments in
my relationship with my husband where i
definitely feel insecure
and i'm just like well what's going on
but then i feel like i need to have
a reason to feel like i don't know it
just won't be like it's not
part of my personality innately to be
like that
it's like if you if i get a reason to to
be insecure then i guess i will i don't
know i don't know
i mean i feel like all of my
relationships have been
um unhealthy ones so it's like quite
obvious
right that i have this behavior now
because i've literally never
in like intertwined my life with a
healthy man
right yeah see i think that's that was
the key it's kind of like
the relationships are obviously two
people so if every single relationship
i've had has been toxic
of course i'm going to be what fearful
avoidant because i'm like
true if i'm by myself then i'm safe
right yeah
sex was really vanilla
well mine comes from like i have jets
okay sorry i'll give you a moment sorry
i know you're mad go ahead nothing's
wrong with vanilla
my favorite flavor mixed with strawberry
yeah so it's not you just gotta mix it
you just gotta throw it from salt and
straw have you had the one from salt and
straw the white chocolate okay we're
getting distracted
so my anxious attachment style stems
from my very first like serious serious
relationship ever he cheated on me oh
multiple times no
yeah so that's yeah me too yeah and it
caused me to like
every relationship afterwards is like um
am i not good enough is this one going
to cheat on me too like
like so it and this was like you gotta
protect yourself right yeah i mean your
introduction to love
is like to be completely [ __ ] over
exactly that's your first
introduction to love exactly so that's
where my anxiousness comes from like are
you gonna [ __ ] me over too what are you
doing you're [ __ ] me over right now
aren't you what are you doing what are
you doing
so yeah and then so that just just that
was my blueprint
you know so it's it's very stressful
being anxious like that yeah i think
like if i were if there was a
relationship beyond steve
after being in this relationship i don't
think i would go back to
how i used to be because now that i've
seen what healthy is and that someone
can accept you for 100
you there's no need for me to be yeah
that anxious anymore
and i feel like i answered these and i
got this but it's almost like i have
more understanding now
it's it's almost like this feels like my
past behavior whereas now as soon as i
felt like uncomfortable or red flags i'd
be like well you don't
you don't make me feel good and this
relationship doesn't feel good so i'll
try to talk it out with you once but if
we're not on the same page i'm just
going to keep moving on yeah
i'm just going to keep i'm not going to
engage in something and stay in an
uncomfortable situation for six months
and just be like
no no no no but wait wait wait but love
me but no no no you know like
i don't think i'm gonna do that behavior
again um but
i've had that my whole eye i mean i
can't ever honestly say i've had a
secure relationship but even though now
i feel very secure in myself it's just
weird
yeah that makes sense that just means
you're ready for a secure relationship
exactly
i've just come to a realization that i'm
scared of people
i'm scared that we want to eat them
people are scary people are scared
yeah yeah because then when they're
close they have power over you you don't
like having that yeah like you just
you're like no no i hold
the power right yeah i totally get that
um
i need you guys to check out our newest
sponsor ernest
say goodbye to stressful student loan
payments and take charge of your future
with
earnest they offer low rate student loan
refinancing and you can check your rate
risk free in just two minutes with
earnest you get radically flexible
payments and you can pick your loan term
by refinancing you can reduce the loan
term save money
or combine multiple loans into a simple
monthly payment
if you have any questions you can even
talk to a real live human
that's great because not a lot of these
companies have real live humans anymore
isn't it time you stop feeling
overwhelmed by your student debt
yes tell me about it ernest is offering
our listeners a hundred dollar cash
bonus
refinance your student debt at
earnest.com big mood
with terms and conditions apply now
ernest is giving our listeners a hundred
dollar bonus refinance your student
loans at earnest.com
big mood of course again terms and
conditions apply
once again you get a 100 cash bonus when
you visit earnest.com
big mood to refinance your student loan
not available in all states
but again terms and conditions apply
visit earnest.com
big mood for more details terms and
conditions apply earnest student loan
refinancing maybe earnings operations
llc and mls number 120497 california
refinance law license number 605 4788
303 second straight 341 in san francisco
california 941.7 visitors.com
licenses for full list of licenses yeah
and once you pay off all your debt you
can sleep really easy especially if
you've got nice sheets i'm talking brook
lyndon we love you brick linen
the sheets feel like you're staying in a
hotel so like but
during the pantalones uh it's nice to
feel like you're at a hotel
with no pantalones no pantalones so
brooklyn was started by rich and vicky
who also tried to find beautiful home
essentials that didn't cost them an arm
or leg and when they couldn't find it
they founded brook linen as the first
direct to consumer bedding company
they work directly with the
manufacturers to make luxury available
directly to you without the luxury level
markups because that's just expensive
we need to make it accessible and they
they do so much more than sheets they
also got
comforters pillows towels even
loungewear
and more i love it so go to brooklyn.com
and use promo code
mood to get 25 off when you spend 100 or
more
plus free shipping yeah baby that's
l i n b-r-o-o-k-l-i-n-e n dot com enter
promo code
mood to get 25 off when you spend 100 or
more
plus free shipping brooklyn.com and use
promo code
mood at checkout the sheets that get
better every time you wash them
pony sheet so moving on to the next
relationship attachment style so this
one was a little different
this one would rate your avoidance of
closeness does that make sense so out of
100
yeah you get rated an intimacy thing
almost
or letting people close like how much
you let your walls down yeah it's like
how
avoidant are you of getting close to
people so a high number means you're
super avoidant
um yes yes yeah yeah 100
avoidance of closeness yes okay that's
super avoidant so the higher the number
the more you are
avoidant of getting close i got 19 out
of 100. oh that's good oh that's really
good
so it says whether it involves emotional
expression or developing a deep
intimate bond you're the type of person
who is very at ease getting close to a
partner
you are also comfortable relying on your
partner when necessary as well as having
him or her dependent
upon you in times of need see again i
got the same two but i got 30.
49. oh my god big range that is a huge
range i feel like they have the same
[ __ ] answer for all of them what was
yours
i got 43. was it the same same answers
huh
yeah it is the same yes whether it
involves yeah yeah what was yours well
all right
30. well there we go is your number 49.
and hers was 19. 19.
yeah weird oh yeah all right well i
guess we're all good
they just didn't really write different
answers but they're like nobody's gonna
compare answers on this [ __ ]
this is psychology today these are
weirdos no one's ever gonna make a
podcast to do our quiz and talk about it
ever
yeah i can get away with this this guy
just wanted to get paid like i did the
[ __ ] test
it's like birmingham
once you hit 75 they're like whoa [ __ ]
you're avoiding it it'll make people
feel good
yeah you got some good some bad see
that's so funny i just feel that it's
true because i feel like i can get
very close to people like i let people
in i'm an open book
but then i start freaking out opposite
yeah yeah i
don't like to let people in at all but
i'll let like a little few in but those
people have so much power
yeah yeah trying to think of like
well i feel like it's definitely
different for me in romantic
relationships versus friendships i feel
like with friendships i
well depend it depends on how that
person makes me feel too
because i guess you obviously react
different to different people when you
meet them but
i would say i probably over share or
like i'll talk a lot or like i'll just
be myself right off the bat which
sometimes isn't the best thing to do
but i don't know if i'm necessarily
really letting them in or not it's hard
to it's hard to say
because then over time it either happens
or it doesn't yeah so i don't know if
i'm
forcefully avoidant or not hmm i think
that's healthy i don't know i can't see
anything wrong with that but maybe
i'm not maybe i'm not closed like like
i'll meet i'll talk to a new person i'll
be like yeah do you like sucking dicks i
like you know i'll over
share and i'll be like there and present
and you know but i just don't know at
what point
are you actually letting somebody yeah
what does it mean to let someone exactly
because i feel like especially being on
this podcast we've shared so many
intimate details
of ourselves those are all lives like
you're all part of the close circle
you're so deep inside of me right now
i think like we're like very open we
talk about everything we let you know
everything but
it's uh i think intimate is more like
okay now you have control over my
feelings and how i feel that day like
closeness to me is like would i respond
to your text
would i answer the phone if you called
me right because
most people maybe not would i drive you
to lax or pick you up from there
yes yeah if you called me at 2am would i
answer the phone
or whatever which kind of goes into the
you're comfortable
relying and also having them dependent
on you in times of need i guess that's
probably where you distinct yeah like
distinguished closeness
like you can know everything about me
but it doesn't mean that i care about
you
or that i'm willing to go out oh yeah i
guess it's more like how much you care
about them yeah their opinions yeah
how close are you so like i can talk to
a room full of people about my [ __ ]
and what it looks like
yeah but do i care like when i start to
care about what they think about me or
whatever like
exactly yeah so maybe that's where the
rating is all right next one
is real ideal relationship structure
i'm very curious about what you guys got
on this yeah me too what if we all got
the same i feel like we got the same
we probably did i think we got we're so
pretty you know gina's out of the box
for me oh true
this is from shan boudream's website
yeah yeah i remember i tweeted my
results she's like
huh i did not think you were one of
those really
yeah okay well you're wrong with
hippopotamus
why did you why do you even need that at
this point
it's really quick yeah i'm probably like
that monogamous synonymous with
hippopotamus the bottomless oh my god
the eminem but you never thought of this
i don't know i could go on for a while
he's in your brain don't tempt me i
don't should i start then since
yeah yeah yeah just stop this anyway uh
i got you are a modern monogamous aka a
cereal monogamous that's god we're
predictable
[Music]
it says uh for you when it comes to
structuring your relationships it's not
out with the old and in with the new
your values are a combination of
traditional and modern concepts of
coupling
this means that while you believe in
exclusivity and unwavering faithfulness
you also believe in letting go of what
or who is holding you back
even if that means divorce people live
longer women are
equal economic contributors and people
[ __ ] yeah
and people's values are shifting thus
the world is outgrowing a
one-size-fits-all concept of love and
until death does part may not fit all of
your goals and needs yeah [ __ ] your
death do us part treat me right
[ __ ] you reserve the right to opt out
and i want to die with you
uh you deserve the right to opt out if
necessary but as long as you choose to
be in you're all in
modern monogamy is the most popular form
of coupling and one that is
depicted most often in media but don't
fall into the trap of taking this for
granted and assuming everyone has the
same
relationship structure goal as you it is
still extremely essential to emphasize
not just how important fidelity is to
you but also to explain why it's
uniquely necessary for you to love and
feel loved and this is compared to like
old school monogamy where it's just like
you said it you committed your divorce
stuck your husband beats you whatever
you get married right out of high school
matter yeah because you need his income
because like you can't have a job
thank you religious background soon no
divorces yeah
well that's cool we all have the same
one yeah i mean
that seems i mean like it's like the
prompt said it's the most common um
it's weird how she's like but don't
think everyone's gonna like that i'm
like okay i get it there's
people that don't want to be tied down
ever never want to be in a monogamous
relationship yeah that's fine or be
fully traditionally monogamous because
this is modern monogamy yeah
i guess the modern part of it is we will
divorce or end the relationship when it
no longer
feels healthy or suiting right yeah i
feel like it's fine
the most common one for sure next one is
love language so we've talked about our
previous languages it has changed
i've changed yeah gina's did change so
gina what was your
your previous one and then what do you
know uh my previous ones my top two was
uh gift receiving gifts and acts of
service i think this is the most
important
one of all of these quizzes like if you
were gonna take one to be able to
express yourself to a new partner
this is like the most important like in
the beginning make sure that these align
otherwise you are just speaking
different languages
all together right so you're saying that
they should have the same language
i'm saying that even if you don't have
the same language you should be able to
cater to
whoever you should be like i'm not
comfortable using gifts
yeah if i hate going to the store i hate
buying things gives me anxiety
like but the only way you feel loved is
like i want little cute things
throughout the week because i want to
give you something to work with oh it's
just you'll never feel loved by hs
same with with me and words of praise
like words of affirmation yeah
i cannot like people that need that one
like they just need it a lot
and i know you're not going to feel
loved by me and that sucks because
even if i love you to the moon like yeah
right you just won't feel it so
true that's i think this is important so
it went from
gifts and access service to
access service and quality time you just
want all the languages don't you
language it's okay to have all of them
no
the thing is everyone has all a little
bit of yeah
i mean yeah base line for a relationship
but there's one that
feels more dominant like yeah if that
person does that one more
for you that it's more fulfilling you
will feel more loved
because if someone only gave me gifts
then i would be like all right where's
the rest of it yeah yeah
exactly so it's you have to be able to
do all five but these are just like the
top two that resonates with you the most
and how
this is also how you prefer to show your
love so the crazy thing is
receiving gifts has kind of moved all
the way down to the bottom
whoa okay so the first time you can buy
your own [ __ ] [ __ ]
exactly the first time i took this quiz
i was younger i was like i want all the
pretty things
i want you know and now i'm like nah
like i want to do nice things for you i
want you to do nice things for me i want
quality time and spend more time with
you and i want physical touch so those
are my top three now
say i want to be close i want to do
things for you i want to be touching and
hanging out all the time
and then it's words of affirmation and
then last one is receiving gifts
i never thought that would happen that's
pretty cool that's amazing yes
yeah good job the gross sick tif did
yours change
um so mine they didn't actually
i don't remember all of that like all of
the orders but the top two
are the same which is number one is
quality time
i got 37 percent for that physical touch
was number two
30 for that one and then like access
service
was 20 and then words of affirmation
seven and receiving gifts were seven so
a world information and receiving gifts
were
tied for the lowest that's how mine is i
didn't get anything
yeah my acts of service and
um quality time were tied and then
physical touch
was right below it like just smidge
i don't remember the percentages mine um
kind of was interesting to me because
i thought touch was at the top of mine
before i don't remember what my scores
used to be
um right now it's quality time at the
top and then acts of service
um i used to think that touch was higher
for me but i don't know if it's because
i've been
single for so long that like i've
gotten used to not being like i don't
know if that's like something like if
you're single for so long you're not
actually touched all the time if you
kind of forget and you're like oh i
i don't know like maybe i don't need
that maybe i just want someone around
like i don't know if like the state of
my life has changed it because i used to
feel like touch was the most important
one i i remember feeling like thinking
like that was the most important one
if you were with a new person right now
would you rather
them like come over and like start doing
physical things or that's weird okay
yeah
for a new person i want the quality time
and i want them like say i'm really busy
and i need help with my dogs or
something like that would mean a lot
more to me than them just trying to [ __ ]
me
so but but for the relationship part
yeah i definitely
still want to be touched and all of that
i'm actually surprised that physical
touch is
my number two yeah that's kind of weird
i don't know like for me
i i would actually have thought like
maybe axe or service
would have been number two i don't know
i really don't know if i had to guess
but
i was really shocked to know that
physical touch was my second one because
i don't really
i know in the past like when i was
younger and like with previous
partners like i would be very very
handsy and like i would be touchy and i
would always like caress their hair
whatever
but then with casey like through
our ups and downs like i just i just
don't have that in me anymore
and i don't really like you know caress
him or touch him or whatever
or cuddle and cuddling is a challenge
because he starts sweating or whatever
like there's always reasons right
so they're just like well [ __ ] i'm
really i'm really surprised i'm
surprised why
i'm surprised that physical touch is so
high up for me because i don't really
feel like i give it a lot or receive it
a lot yeah with isaac
oh yeah we hug a lot there you go yeah
we hug a lot i need a lot of hugs
i mean case and i hug a lot too actually
and like we we do kiss but it's mainly
like
maybe i don't notice it i don't know
like i don't know
it's not like we don't you definitely do
but
isaac it's more noticeable because he he
comes in like he needs a lot of physical
touch that's exactly
like a lot i like to be alone but then
like at least three times throughout the
day i'll i'll run downstairs and get a
hug from steve and then go back up to my
right office or you can see like even on
episodes i'm just always
yeah you know like i have to feel you
i'm like and
physical touch has has become such a big
thing for me now
it's to the point where like if you
leave the house without kissing me
goodbye oh no
oh yeah no we're gonna fight yeah yeah
in the thunderdome [ __ ]
dude i have a particular buy when
casey's like all right i'm heading out
and i'm like
bye and he goes oh yeah sorry i forgot
yeah he's like a tone and then sometimes
he'll do it to me too like because i'll
i'll just play around and not give him a
kiss on purpose like to
leave and i'm like all right i'm leaving
he goes bye and i was like
oh yeah he remembered that's cool
i was gonna go anyway and give him a
kiss but i like quality time
isn't like a i want you to be there but
we don't have to be
really interacting just yeah you want to
be under our skin be there i've heard
this
that's oh you have that too get out get
out of there that's you
it's like you're gonna eat it too it's
yeah it's like i'm eating my
it's either there it's it's like i'm
both i'm like i when i cuddle you like
i can't get close enough i want to be
inside your skin you know i gotta get
closer but then at the same time quality
time is in like
i want to see you almost all the time
but we don't have to be doing the same
thing just
just on the couch over there yeah yeah
i'm done for that interesting
yeah i don't know if i feel like that's
quality for me yeah yeah
like i need to be engaged in a
conversation like no phones you look
we're looking at each other right yeah
yeah i'm a blend of both
that might be yeah though i do require
that too engage
the engagement is important but yeah
sometimes you just want to disengage a
little but you still like their presence
yeah yeah true because sometimes casey
will go work downstairs in the kitchen
i'll be in the office like working all
day and i'm like
wait but you're working too why not work
in the office next to me or your desk is
right next week
like a team like are you going to come
upstairs and work in the office and then
so he'll like because he's more
like he needs that alone time sometimes
oh i just need to
be doing this yes he's going to be
focused on so then he'll come to the
office
and he'll be with me for a little bit
just to kind of like shut me up and then
he'll leave
yeah he's like that like your cat that
like tucks you into bed and then
waits you're sleeping exactly freaking
maya is so cute okay
last one guys this one is the apology
language quiz
this quiz was hard for me because yeah
picturing all these fictitious scenarios
i was getting
so triggered it was like
you you failed at a project but your
co-worker blames you for everything even
though they're the ones that
did a lot of the failing and i'm like oh
i hate you
die i don't want you to apologize i want
you to not exist like where's the option
to fight them yeah
i don't know there was no option that
felt good but i guess this one
and i hated the ones that were like i
hope you can find it in your heart to
forgive me
yeah that sounds so so selfish
it sounded sarcastic to me yeah i know i
was reading some of you you might not be
ready for it yet but i hope eventually
they'll forgive me
yeah they wanted to fight nikki what'd
you get oh i got
make restitution in our society many
people believe that wrong acts demand
justice the one who commits the
crime should pay for their wrongdoing a
person who speaks this love language
feels the same way towards apologies
they believe in order to be sincere the
person who is apologizing should justify
their actions
the partner who's been hurt simply wants
to hear that their counterpart still
loves them
and then there's uh many effective ways
to demonstrate sincerity and an apology
uh learn each partner's love language
and then like do that love language to
like make restitution basically
but the like in the prompts they'd be
the answers that's like
hey i [ __ ] up they own it they're like
i [ __ ] up what can i do to make this
better
like can i um can i go do this to make
up for it or whatever
interesting because when i read those
those also pissed me off because it felt
like
how can i get my way out of this what do
you want me to do
to shut up that's actually how i felt
about it i didn't like to make i didn't
like those earlier what can i do to get
out of it or like a promise to do
like i mean next time this happens i'm
gonna do this that one i liked
but the one where they would just leave
it up to me to solve yeah like that's
telling you
yeah yeah like you want me to tell you
how to get out of this like you [ __ ]
figure out what the right thing to do
maybe that wasn't the one it was the
ones where they're like there's
a specific action attached to i like
that yeah those were like they came up
with it
yeah like they come up with like if
they're like i'm sorry i'm gonna
i'm gonna do this yes it feels better
than tell me
what you want me to do to fix it yeah
please let me buy you lunch
please let me buy you dinner or whatever
that kind of thing was
yeah that's like the the one that's the
one mine was uh
expressing regret i got that one too you
got that one did you get that one nope
oh okay um expressing regret zeroes in
on emotional hurt it's an admission of
guilt and shame
or causing pain to another person for
those who listen for the
expressing regret apologies a simple i'm
sorry is all they look for
actually that one no that one says
that one sentence in this thing i'm like
are you [ __ ] kidding me that's wrong
because when you just say i'm sorry i
[ __ ] hate that but anyways this
prompt is
not quite there yeah just delete that
sentence it says there's no need for an
explanation or a payback provided the
apology has truly come from the heart
and i do kind of
agree with that like yeah i don't
necessarily need to pay back or like an
equal but opposite reaction of the
positive it just seems to show that they
meant it like they genuinely meant it
and i think
there's different ways of interpreting
them
showing it yes taking ownership right
yeah just like with love like you can
love someone by giving them something or
by doing something for them
it's it's all expressing love yeah this
is like expressing
regret regret or expressing an apology
like i really
am trying to apologize to you this is i
guess yeah you're looking
to get to me and jess like it's a
sincere commitment to repair and rebuild
the relationship and right for some of
those prompts that they had like
tell me what i need to do it doesn't
feel like a sincere
right yeah that's why the the offering
to do something
like to make up for it it falls in line
with this in my opinion because it's
like well
you are trying to uh what did it say to
repair and rebuild the relationship like
a sincere commitment to it which is like
oh my god
i ruined your shirt i'm so sorry let me
buy you another shirt
to me it kind of falls in line with that
too but if you're asking me like
i'm sorry i ruined your shirt what do
you want me to do right right
yeah for yourself the replacing the
shirt one that's the one i picked with
it's like
hey let me dry clean that for you yeah
exactly i i really hated the
i feel like the freak oh will you
forgive me or like will you it's well
you work for them
can you find it in your heart to forgive
me oh makes them feel better
yeah i don't need to like especially
right now when you did something wrong
what did yours
get mine is accept responsibility it is
very difficult for some people to admit
that they're wrong it makes them doubt
their self-worth and no one likes to be
portrayed as a failure
however as adults we must all admit that
we are sinners and that we will make
mistakes jesus
sinners
[Laughter]
we are going to make poor decisions that
hurt our mates and we are going to have
to admit that we are wrong
we have to accept responsibility for
their for our own failures
for many individuals all they want to
hear is the words i am wrong if the
apology neglects accepting
responsibility for their actions
many partners will not feel as though
the apology was meaningful and sincere
many parties many partners need to know
learn how to overcome their ego
the desire to not be viewed as failure
and simply admit their actions were
wrong
for a mate who speaks this apology
language if an apology does not admit
fault it is not worth hearing
being sincere in your apology means
allowing yourself to be weak and
admitting that you make mistakes though
this may be hard to do for some people
it makes a world of difference to your
partner who speaks this language i feel
like that one goes hand-in-hand with the
regret one too
like you have to acknowledge
responsibility in order to sincerely
express regret that's most important to
me because
i grew up in a family of like well i
mean
yeah i'm sorry but i didn't you know i
didn't i'm even that big of a deal
yeah like i need to i need you to be
like
i am wrong and this is why i'm wrong and
that's how i apologize too like i'm so
sorry
i'm wrong um you know i take full
responsibility for it like
that's just it feels more genuine to me
because
it shows that you understand what you
did and you understand how it affected
me yeah
i had an ex that um had some anger
issues and the only thing he wanted to
hear was i'm sorry
and so it's it's interesting that that's
like a thing that they had in here
because for me
that does nothing for me but i could i
could so with this
relationship i could admit fault i could
express guilt
if i'm missing those two words i'm sorry
like if i just hadn't got to that or if
i'm so busy
explaining myself or like trying to make
it up or trying to just explain like
where my thought was at the time or
something and so i never actually like
he would just wait and listen for me to
say i'm sorry and
so i would spend like an hour
apologizing and like trying to make this
right
and it it did nothing and he just wanted
to hear i'm sorry like some weird
like to me that was just so weird like a
weird power trip or something
i'm like i've literally expressed for an
hour how it was wrong what i'm going to
try to do better blah blah blah but you
just want to hear i'm sorry
yeah that's me too i need to hear that
because i i don't know what it is it's i
think it's because i feel that
it's such a hard thing for someone to
say that if you're
willing to like set your ego aside um
your ego and your pride aside admit that
you're wrong and just say that you're
sorry
it means it shows me that i matter to
you
like i matter more than you having to be
right you having to
win this argument you ha like but if i'm
not trying to win it right if i'm like
i broke this rule our of our agreement
this is where i went wrong i sincerely
regret this i wish i had done it
differently like next time i'll know not
to do this blah blah blah like i
literally apologize every possible way
but i just happen to not have said those
two words
the whole thing is worthless and i'm
like are you kidding me
like for me i had it it wasn't in my
brain it was like i would only hear
those two words and nothing else and i'm
like oh
my blood is boiling i don't want to hear
those two words those two they feel like
they feel yeah exactly
it's just like you can just see this the
magical beans that are
gonna grow the stock and i'm gonna climb
my way out of it yeah no i want to hear
all the other [ __ ] it can't just be that
no
yeah i need to know why you did it like
then the reasoning your reasoning like
how did you get there
because if your reasoning is flawed then
i then i think it's gonna happen again
exactly right
the sorry means nothing yeah right and i
need to know where that you recognize
where you went wrong
and that you're not gonna do it again
like you're gonna promise me you're not
gonna do it again
and then if it does happen again then we
have a problem like you have a big
problem that's not yeah
there's no patterns that are gonna
happen i i like i
respect people so much more when they're
willing to apologize and admit they're
wrong because
i'm a very um in relationships and stuff
i'm a very
uh like a dominant confident person
my ego is there also but and if i'm
dating someone else like that and
they're willing to lay that down
it just shows how much you care and if
i'm willing to lay that down too
and apologize that means i really really
care and and if i can
you know and if i can and you respect
your partner yes exactly i will lay that
all aside if i care
enough to actually respect everything
yeah yeah and then knowing all these
results to these
these quizzes like just in within our
friendship is really
helpful because then we could know how
to be better friends to one another
yeah you guys out there make sure to
take these quizzes make sure and discuss
them with your partner
yeah your partner or your friends if you
don't have a partner it's also helpful
or your therapist if you realize you
take a quiz and you're like oh my god i
think i'm anxious
like that might help them you know if
you're starting with a new therapist
exactly well i know where to start yeah
yeah so
get to know yourself if you don't
already and write in the comments if you
guys would like to share what you guys
got yeah we'll have the quizzes in the
description if you want to take them so
yeah
for sure and check them out make sure to
rate us five stars
give this video a thumbs up and see you
next time
[Music]
[Laughter]